it was really cool to see Max is coming
out oh my gosh I just it makes me cry I
just I loved it so much did you have
some pride in yourself knowing that your
parenting alright dubrow's well hello
from separate corentin´s though you are
quarantined together Terry is just at
work right now right it's so yeah
distancing from me I think it might be a
problem I'm in operating room number two
at my surgeries that are between surgery
cases today we're up and running we're
actually also shooting botched
practicing complete Coban safe protocols
but we're doing everything we need to do
to make sure we have a safe season but
before then we get you guys on celebrity
call center celebrity cause well I
thought it was a really fun idea and
it's it's really interesting to hear all
the different perspectives of the
celebrities and it's also peculiarly
funny to be honest with you I found it
it wasn't it funny it was ridiculously
entertaining
Heather is sort of a modern-day Mary
Poppins in the way right but she's
always got sort of the straightforward
accurate amusing opinion about what to
do and it's Heather's world and we're
just living in it right I always say I'm
just a little squirrel and Heather's
world just trying to get a few nuts
that's all like that that's good enough
you're plenty of nuts dear cue the
Heather Dubrow Sapporo theme song now
Heather Dubrow zwerling you're kind of
used to giving advice as part of your
podcast what would you say is the best
advice you've ever been given in length
treat people like there's a camera on
you and an audience is watching who gave
you that you did because Heather gave me
that advice and that's really good
advice because if you knew you were
being televised or being video recorded
you would tenth you always go to your
best self your best behavior to Terry's
point I always say like parent like
someone's watching because I think that
if a kid if you knew people were
watching you and you were being held
accountable you would really be your
best self
I think housewives may prove otherwise
to that theory this is not okay this is
not doing this just saying maybe we get
a little comfortable there but I would
say that I'm kind of really trying to
hold myself accountable to my what I do
and what I say and how I act and then
the family that are praising it was
really cool to see
Max's coming out and the kind of pride
no pun intended that was surrounding
that oh my gosh I just it makes me cry I
just I loved it so much I had known for
some time but I didn't realize that she
was about to put this out into the world
and I had just come home from somewhere
ran an errand came home at like purse on
my shoulder and she goes mom did you see
my post and I go No
so looked at the post it's so you know
the caption she wrote is so max it's so
funny so I started laughing and I go oh
my god I love this this is great I said
can I repost this and she goes yeah okay
I go just so you know if I repost it
people are gonna pick it up it's gonna
become a thing she was like no no you go
ahead you repost it I went okay I just I
loved her confidence and I thought the
response was amazing
of course my mother called me she's like
why did I have to find out that my
granddaughter is by on Katie Mike
because I didn't think I'm sorry what I
loved about it was Max had never
discussed it with us maybe Heather but
certainly never discussed it with me
I always weirdly knew and so when she
posted it it was like da but one of the
things I like look there's a lot of
problems societally that we're working
through now and we need to continue
working through but it made me feel good
that at least in today's worlds one of
the brighter spots is that you don't
have to be embarrassed or insecure or
anxious necessarily about coming out and
she felt free and the acceptance of her
coming out was so amazing yeah and I
think his parents you know what makes me
so happy is that she is so confident and
comfortable in who she is and has our
full support I knew for a long she had
discussed this with me
for a long time but I loved it was just
like and then it was just Tuesday you
know and and that's just the way it
should be so this was just kind of an
open dialog thing conversation you guys
have been having for a while oh yeah
something that was so exciting for me is
that I come from a very like very nice
family but very like 1950s buttoned up
no one talks about anything so knowing
this for some time it was so exciting to
me that she just you know felt ready to
tell the world and she was so confident
about it and it was so such the opposite
of how I grew up that I just felt like
this family and this DNA is evolving and
I love it and again just as a parent to
be able to see you want your kids to be
happy that's number one but to be able
to see your kids being happy and just
putting it out there it's just but it
just feeds my soul did you have some
pride in yourself knowing that your
parenting helps me to that moment yes
I'm back yes what advice would you have
for parents who are maybe going to have
to have those conversations so I have
gotten so many messages not just when
Max came out but also because you know
our youngest daughter Coco likes to wear
quote boy clothes and she's been a point
of conversation for many years I've
gotten so many messages from people
about how they wish they had been
different with their kids they wish they
had listened to kids you know that have
you know gone down the wrong path after
not getting the correct support that
they needed you know we all come from
where we come from you can't control
where you come from but you can't
control where you go to so to really
listen to your kids and be less reactive
and keep an open mind and understanding
that where you come from might not be
the same place where your kids are going
to and try to figure it out because at
the end of the day this is your family
this is who we have and if the last few
months if told us taught us nothing we
have to stay together and stay close and
love each other Heather said it
beautifully but my advice in these
situations for parents is do more
listening than talking when you are
talking remember it's not about you it's
about your child so even if you have
preconceived notions and even if you
have sort of prejudices based on the way
you were raised let it go
listen shut up and do whatever needs to
be done to make sure your child is happy
and well balanced that's what you do and
are you guys ready for the next step of
her dating and exploring all of this and
introducing you to people yeah I mean
we're already there and we're good and
and I love it I just you know what like
I said it's all about happy healthy
functioning kids we are so lucky to have
these four healthy amazing kids they're
not perfect we're not perfect we're
doing the best we can we don't know
everything but we're smart enough to
know we don't know everything we have an
experience absolutely everything but we
do have our own experiences so you
listen you keep your mouth shut you try
to figure it out and you just support
and that's what we do for each other - I
mean that's relation
ships in general right well speaking of
relationships there is a new project in
the works the seven years stitch could
you have a 7-year itch in this
relationship because you just celebrated
21 years of marriage right yeah no I
don't think it was it wasn't for us it
wasn't seven for us it was like it was
the third year a housewife so I use the
D word I don't even know if I don't say
that I mean we've had I mean every seven
years or so we will have bumps in the
road I think that you either work
through and get to the next stage a next
level or you regress and possibly have a
problem and this show basically will
bring all of our resources to bear both
in terms of counseling divorce attorneys
finances plastic surgery training our
personal experiences onto couples who
are really at that point in a
relationship with you know things are
really tough and this is that critical
point where they could stay together if
they get help or they may break up this
is gonna be for me the best reality
project that I've never been involved
don't you think so honey
I do do you think this will finally mean
the project that makes people stop
asking you when are you coming back to
house no I don't think I'm gonna be like
carting you off to the nursing home
instead I will say our friend Tamra just
went on a podcast and kind of spoke on
your behalf about your exit from the
show why do you think they got rid of
her I think it was a personal thing I
really do I think it was a personal
conflict was with an executive at Bravo
is what I think she wanted things done a
certain way but trust me there's people
in the cast right now in a way worse way
worse was she shocked oh yeah yeah she
it she took it bad it was hard for her I
think what they wanted to do is just
kind of smack her around and say you
know what here's a part-time role and
then the next year they probably woulda
brought her back how do you feel about
her kind of
speaking on your behalf she texted me
some article with I'm sorry I didn't say
that what I said was this whatever and I
kind of like glanced at it but we were
somewhere and then later I looked at
whatever you know what could I say to
that
you know what no one should speak for me
except me so if you want to now ask me
but I will tell you this as I always say
I was five seasons on the show which was
an amazing run Terry and I got so much
out of being on the show it did so much
for our platform it's brought us so many
amazing things to our family even with
my daughter max I feel like that's why
she has a platform and that's why she
had a moment to speak out and that is
all based on the fact that we got
catapulted into the spotlight from being
on Housewives so I'm always forever
grateful
[Music]